man this studio smells really weird
today it's like a mix of like coal [ __ ]
sauerkraut dad it's like iron
that's that blood oh yeah breakfast what
is the oh oh yeah sleek schmear
yeah that's why yes Peter this is Alicia
Pierre that name
we might be butchering but this is an
interesting game it really goes for it
as far as the humor goes it's definitely
got some deutsche influence does the
humor extend beyond hey this sounds a
little German
I can't it's okay if not as long as it
works it's mostly this but so the goal
here is I'm chucking Spears oh wait is
this like is this is winter coming is
this what's happening yeah I got that
vibe too but white walkers
yeah some of the the Giants so I'm
clearly Oh what dude walrus that was he
came out of nowhere he was actually in
the foreground is he wearing glasses yep
he sure is this game holds nothing back
so all of uncensored glasses so I'm
clearly throwing spears here yeah now
you have some of these kind of archers
sometimes there's like mages in the back
who are like throwing projectiles that
you are also trying to hit but obviously
if I miss a throw I lose my combo oh god
I feel like those I feel like those
yetis are there to chill like they're
just kind of slowly trotting over its
these other guys in the hats that are
trying to kill you absolutely are more
often than all the ones that are killing
me look at homee he's just you just
coming to hang on so yeah you uh you you
know the goal is you want headshots for
the most part misses kill your combo get
this guy so alright so I actually have a
move so on the upper left you know there
is a kind of progression tree as far as
abilities that can like I have like last
resort like beams that I can I can't
remember the button prompts reach said
ability but hun oh this is it
dang it dang is it still charging I
think it is it's not a cool-down I don't
know why it's not
whoof
you get pretty close sometimes and
that's probably the most exhilarating
part is when you get that last man this
guy is tricky all right that's it
walrus a gun yeah how do you deal with
him you just got to get him before he
takes off yeah for the most part yeah
those guys in the back are the ones that
you really want to worry about sooner
than later there we go
you'll get like two or three of those a
game so yeah they're different enemy
types so I also have abilities like oh
[ __ ] oh oh your your body is bleeding
yeah all right I got this so this is a
pretty like casual game and I want to
call it you know it reminds me of like
an iOS obviously is like you know
perfect for like on the go oh no this is
the only character you can you can play
as or the female and the beginning oh
wow do they have the same sort of like
controls like in terms of how sensitive
the stick is and there are there are
settings like I actually raise the
sensitivity to quite a bit yeah in order
to like have them split reactions right
yeah all right so then there's like that
so you get like these obviously
different abilities so when I get past
this I think this might be one of the
last stages there's a boss obviously in
each stage mark here so obviously those
guys are two hits if you don't give them
the face I do love how impactful that
all feels when they're getting their
heads chopped off I'm not even playing
yeah there is a sense of reward you got
that Daddy okay say you just kind of
progressed through these stages
underwear this is the third or are you
wearing a suit now you've got a full
suit like a full state action
so looks like I have that other ability
oh and they change it up definitely like
local you and like a crowded hallway
these flying guys are kind of rough oh
here we go here's that mage I was
talking about you got to worry about his
balls of energy this is the soundtrack
speak like across the level in the
various stages of a given level does it
revolve like it seems like this song has
another layer to it that it didn't any
interest
like is the tempo the tempo is the same
but it's like they've added like an
extra instrument I'm where well you know
it's interesting actually is a lot of
swished games when I'm in handheld I
have something else on in the background
oh so you don't hear them yeah I do
oh wow and actually I'm playing on the
pro controller so we can capture you are
a pro I am a pro oh it actually feels
way much better as you would expect we
honest anything with the pro controller
is legit nice so let's see I can use
this ability here uh nope hey watch this
watch this there is a sense of reward
when you're comboing
those headshots there's nothing worse
than a Miss how'd you get to unlock and
you sort of like a new equipment yeah
you get new abilities right if there are
also you know like stat boosts and
health and stuff I actually when we're
done with this sorry if we're ever done
with this I'll show you the tree it
actually never ends the bosses have the
bosses have been pretty fun they're
there so far they've been pretty diverse
oh there it is
that's the I wasted it yeah
oh there were times where I was yelling
by myself just like real close calls and
that is such a white Walker
so hear the song now and I think it'll
add another instrument or something or
I'm crazy I'm just hearing case I
haven't heard anything
I think it's that sort of melodic thing
happening okay guys got a single shade
pair of glasses worth it where's that
come from Oh see that's the thing is I
keep sometimes here are these these
characters I feel like they're just part
of the environment let's get out of here
to zoom out dust flies yeah show me this
upgrade tree and then I definitely can
unlock something okay so my leash stop
shop here and get to it so here's when I
unlocked here that's the one I wear I
threw triple in midair I couldn't engage
it yeah these these are kind of your
last resort moves to counter guy who's
close to you so this one just looks like
a fires a beam maybe a hail of leash
rain and then obviously you have so
here's a shield that you can engage so
yeah you got a you know a few abilities
here let's continue well do you want to
see one check out the coop real quick
yeah let's do that
I I don't know what this looks like oh
no we see you have to you have to hit
start and select simultaneously on your
controller for that previous screen
right no way you're gonna kick your
you're a dachshund uh-huh that is pretty
adorable yes I know man yeah I wish the
sensitivity was turned up
okay here we go well this is pretty neat
together I feel like we can kill the
world I I feel like we kind of my friend
I wonder if the enemies are taking more
hits as well so in that in the upper
left there is that I got fat cooldown
you have maybe oh it's like yeah it's
like some kind of meter I think for
every kill it's filling up and then you
have some kind of alt I'll get that fish
nice you know this games alright I could
play this I could play the coop I well I
got that guy right in that Johnson no no
Elena oh I really like that dachshund
you like toxins I'm not a dachshund man
but this guy he in bed kinda want that
dog well this seems like a natural exit
is any yeah there's been leash spear
least should be it is that on switch now
share it I believe it's also out on PC
yeah alright thanks for watching
everyone have a good day
see you guys
you